est sur les ailes de
- le mieux ouais un deux trois
relâchement clé je suis un père qu'est-ce qui se passe ici
ce qu'il est dans notre famille vous réunissant
pour vous présenter et vous le gâchez je veux que vous
apportiez une date au mariage de votre sœur nous
je ne veux pas que tu te
montres entre amis et que tu
t'énerves on ne s'énerve pas on
ne s'arrangera jamais ouf Jeannie on doit trouver
les bonnes filles pour ça où allons-nous
même ce que nous sommes sur le point de faire quelque chose de
génial  Je suis ici avec Mike et Dave
Stengel Dave cherche des dates pour le
mariage de leurs sœurs à Hawaï faisons en
sorte que ces gars nous emmènent nous
recherchons des filles sympas nous allons avoir l'air
respectables car elles partent tout cela fait
partie du  plan est-ce que tu vas bien je suis maintenant je t'ai
sauvé la vie grand-mère rencontre Alice elle est
super intelligente Tatiana elle est
institutrice la clé pour enseigner aux
enfants est la répétition tu serais
surpris de voir à quel point ils sont stupides jouons à la
pétanque nous y allons doucement absolument maintenant nous
devrions les laisser  perdre avec dignité
c'est ce que j'aimerais  pense que nous ferions,
nous avons des briseurs de [ __ ] qui sonnent comme si
vous regardiez du porno ou ils
ont le père de la tige Je ne sais pas si
nous allons l'obtenir bien que nous n'ayons pas
vu le bébé du parrain Donny je suis  une
petite chienne bizarre qui sont ces filles
est-ce que cela signifie nous faire paraître cool Oh
Superman ton temps je ne fais jamais ça
faire tout ce qu'ils pourraient faire c'est
bon elle est comme la victime du bouton Barbie et
ton Ken noir
toi